Good morning, everyone at work.   We will
begin Part 1 of Choi Seul-gi's Morning Briefing, sharing the warmth of happy investing, on Monday, July 6th, the start of a new week.
Uh, yesterday was
last Friday, right?  Let's look into the situation regarding the Chinese market
.
Yes, last Friday the
Shanghai Index rose 0.37% as large-cap stocks rebounded
.  The Shenzhen Tech Index
rose 1%.  Stock market trading volume
maintained a level of 3.2 trillion yuan.
Looking at the sectors, consumer discretionary,
energy, and industrial sectors showed strength,
while consumer staples, communication, and
IT sectors showed weakness.
EV-related stocks rose quite a bit last Friday due to news such as strong EV export data for May
.  BYD
rose 5.86%, SAIC Motor
2.3%, Yuxitongle 0.7%, and
Sanhua District nearly 9%.
Uh, energy-
related stocks rose again last Friday due to high expectations for Kovey.
PetroChina rose 2.7%,
Sinopec up 2%, and Winsun Coal
rose 5%.
Well, regarding energy-related stocks, there are
no special issues.
Machinery-related stocks showed strength again on news such as May machine sales data exceeding expectations
.  Samil Heavy Industries rose 5% at midnight, and
Seogong Machinery went up nearly 3%
.
Fiberglass-related stocks have also
risen due to expectations of further price increases.  China Geoseo rose 4% at midnight
, while Jungja Tech and Gujasinjae also
increased by 4%.
Uh, PCB and CCL-related stocks also
rebounded.  Seung-i Tech rose 5.8%,
Dongsan Precision 5%, Seonnancheongneung 7%, and
Bojeon Stock also rose 3.7%.
However, it is not a historical record high.  It
dropped a lot last Thursday.
Apple-related stocks also rose in tandem.
Goreprion rose by 1%, and Imsinjeongsim
rose by 5.8%.  On the other hand, optical communication-
related stocks were also a bit, well, sluggish.
I thought that the arbitration 5000 was -2.4% unnecessary.
Companies like Tencent have a large market capitalization.
And right now, the forward PER is only 11 times
.  And
because there were so many concerns about CAPEX investment, the
stock price kept falling.
However, those results can be achieved consistently
.   hmm.   I
view such companies strictly based on their PER,
and I also think that companies like Xiaomi are
unnecessary.
Xiaomi's forward PER has now
dropped to 14 times.  However, the
lowest level in history is 10 times.
There is some room for a slight drop, but
looking at the earnings, well,
there is also a possibility that it won't fall that much relative to performance.
However, since the prices of properties on the market have been continuously rising lately,
investors were so worried that the stock price remained
sluggish.   We often
categorize U.S. companies as either asset-heavy or asset-light, and
tend to divide them so that semiconductor companies are doing very well while software companies are doing poorly. But
listening to you, it seems that platform companies in Asia are having
poor stock performance.   I
remember Manager Oh mentioning in Korea, "Ah, Naver's valuation is like this."   Since it
is a stock that needs to be watched closely to see how it performs during the reaction to those things and when it recovers its valuation, as for
Tencent... um,
uh,
I will definitely keep an eye on it, but you are
right, as it is a top-tier stock by market capitalization.
Right?
I think I'll be the first to get attention when I lift it.   The
issue stock is Gukja Materials.
Yes, it was the first company to bring in ladle materials
.  Currently, Hou Chuan's
market capitalization is about 20 trillion won, and its forward
PR is high.  It is at the 98-fold level.
Uh, it was a Chinese chute ceramic material manufacturing
company.  We
produce and sell ceramic materials, including major MLCCs.   If
you look at major clients, Samsung Electro-Mechanics,
Hollystone, Murata, Kyocera, Samhwan
Electronics, and Donghwa Tech are all MLCC-
related stocks.
First-quarter sales increased by 5% compared to the same period last year
.  Net profit increased by 5% compared to the same period last year, but
came out somewhat flat compared to the forecast.  The GP margin
was 32.7% and the NP margin
was 13.9%.  It
fell slightly again compared to the same period last year.
Net profit deteriorated slightly due to one-time factors such as rising raw material prices and foreign exchange losses
.  This company
proposed a price increase starting in March.  Started.
So, we can probably reflect these results starting from the second quarter
.
The company currently has a production capacity of approximately 10,000 tons of
MLCC ceramic materials
.  We are
pursuing the expansion of our annual production capacity for automotive MLCC ceramic materials for AS parts to 5,000 tons
.  Of these, 40% have already
started mass production since the end of last year.
Mass production of the remaining 60% is scheduled to begin at the end of this year
.
Originally, MLCC
manufacturers raised their prices from March to May.
In particular, Murata and Samsung Electro-Mechanics are
raising rates by about 14–15% compared to 10%, respectively
.  Therefore, we decided to increase
the price of MLCC ceramic materials by about 15% rather than 10%
.  The content states that general
MLCC ceramic materials cost around 60,000
yuan per ton, usually around 70,000 yuan
.  The GP margin is coming out at 33%
.  Next, the MLCC
ceramic material for A servers costs about 100,000 yuan per ton
.  So, we are selling it at roughly 50% to
60% higher prices
.  The GP margin is also coming out at 45% to 50%
.   Due to strong
overall demand and supply constraints, the
company's
debt to Kia surged by 212.5% ​​compared to the previous quarter as of the end of last year
.  The first quarter is also maintaining a similar level
.  Uh, the GP Morgan
report is out.  Uh, we presented a buy recommendation based on positive factors such as the expansion of the sales proportion of high-priced, high-value-added
products and an increase in ASP
.
EPS for next year and the year after next was originally estimated at 0.85, 1.2, and
2.45 yuan, respectively, representing upward revisions of
approximately 1%, 22%, and 28% from previous estimates
.
For next year's target, we applied an 88x PR and
proposed a TP of approximately 130x.  It is being adjusted upward significantly by about 125% from the previous level, and
there is a 50% upside compared to yesterday's closing price.
thank you   yes
.
As you noted on the second line here,
global MLCC-related
companies such as Murata, Samsung Electro-Mechanics, TDK, and
Kyocera are
customers of this supplier. Since the business conditions for these customers are
excellent and the
unit prices of their products are rising, the supplier is also raising its
supply
prices. Consequently, it appears that these factors are
continuously being reflected in earnings and valuations, causing the stock price to surge
as shown in the PER and PBR charts below
.   that's
right.
Uh, from the perspective of Chinese individual investors in particular, if they have
the idea that they should buy Samsung Electro-Mechanics or Murata, but
cannot do so directly because it is an investment that crosses the border, then they can simply
buy these companies.   Uh
, yes.  Since the foreigner limit starts at the last 3%, it is a
stock that foreigners cannot buy, and a
stock that individuals cannot buy.
Stocks that cannot be bought.
Whenever this company is mentioned,
[snorting] they
also often talk about that related domestic company
.  Is that company just
Daeju
Electronic Materials?   that's
right.  We talk a lot about that
.  Or, as far as I
know, there aren't that many companies doing this kind of work, and in terms of
global ceramic materials, this company is
probably number
one in the world.   hmm.
This is the company.  The
market share is almost 20%, or about
20% to 30%.  However, you know that
ceramic material.
There is MLCC, and there
are various other directions leading into the dental field as well.  So,
this company accounts for only about
20% of the total MLCC market.   hmm.   yes
.   hmm.
So, you might think that this market isn't very big
.   It is because
the market is small
, or uh, because the upstream
industries are so diverse, the suppliers are quite
dispersed.   that's
right.  Or, you know,
there are companies like this, like Murata.  He also
has ceramic material.   hmm.   Because
it is vertically integrated.
This company is number one, but every individual company
has its own business like this.
Um, yes.   I
get the feeling that this is one of the stocks with the highest beta at the very tail end of the MLCC substrate market.   that's
right.   As for
valuation, the
P/E ratio is currently 98 times based on the forward.  And since the book value has
exceeded 10 times, it
seems that these favorable business conditions and the positive narrative of the market are already largely reflected in the valuation.
you're right.
I have that thought again.  So,
when you invest, please also pay attention to volatility,
yes.   I’m
thinking we should invest. You
agree, right?
Yes, that is correct.
Rather than feeling that we must make a firm decision on direct investment today, let's
move on by understanding the situation from the perspective that such a company exists in this industry climate
.   I'll be
looking at the virtual asset market and the US market
.  The
reason for the change today is that the
U.S. market was
closed yesterday, Friday. Therefore, we will review
the content covered in Part 2 with Vice President Choi Yi-rak in Part 1, and then
move directly to the domestic market in Part 2
.  If there
was anything lacking in Part 1, we can do another Q&A in Part 2
.
Please listen to the end.  First, changing the order,
yes, I will talk about the virtual asset market.
First, the 72-hour price trend
broke through to around $62,900.  So, the 200-day
moving average is around the $500 line between $62,300 and $62,300
.
It was a weekend flow that settled firmly on the line first.  So, looking at it from a
short-term, fragmentary perspective,
I think it can be viewed as very positive.
However, as I will
explain further later, there are currently
no signs of large-scale accumulation or any trends of investors turning a crisis into an opportunity
.  So, we need to track those aspects and
verify them. I believe we can view the
current preference for risky assets not as a bias, but
as a signal of overall risk asset preference
.  If
you look at the right side, as I mentioned earlier, you
can consider that it has now settled above the bottom red line of the 200-week moving average, and
we just need to check first whether it holds this line
.   If you scroll down and
look at the Bitcoin Fuel and Grid Index, it is still
recording around 23, which is in the extreme fear zone
.   If you
look at the net inflow and net outflow of Bitcoin spot ETFs on the right, it seems that the outflow wasn't that significant last
week, perhaps because there was no Friday
.   Uh, as of
last Thursday,
about 220 million was leaked.   There
was an outflow of about 520 million over the past week, but if we consider, for example,
Friday as well, I
personally think there was basically an outflow of around 700 million
.
I think we can just briefly explain the key issues I just mentioned and move on.  Oh, I
wrote in the title that it is "Investors who do not turn crises into opportunities."
Bitcoin has consistently created situations where the return relative to risk is high, as it repeatedly fluctuates patternedly, consolidates a short-term bottom, and
utilizes periods of extreme psychological fear as opportunities for accumulation
.  So, whenever there was a significant short-term
drop, situations continued to unfold where investors
accumulated shares and reaped large returns
.  However, in the current
situation, such hints are
not being found.  Bitcoin has recently
started to rebound, but to determine if the situation is somewhat similar to that of March of this year, we
need to track whether related stocks are rising without being left out due to the concentration on semiconductors. On Friday,
although it was fragmentary, I think we can conclude that such a trend
continued
.  So, despite the Bitcoin market being
skewed toward semiconductors on Friday, there
was a slight rise.  However,
I would like to explain the two photos below
.  It is said that there is a net inflow of market makers
.  So, if you look at the market maker
net inflow chart, the
yellow line on the left shows traces of
large-scale accumulation even in areas with extreme fluctuations
.  With a sudden surge in trading volume,
there was demand from those looking to buy and accumulate this.  So,
however, if
you look at the demand represented by the red line on the right, it seems you can statistically confirm that the market is not using
the zone of extreme fear as an opportunity for accumulation while falling
.  Uh,
as another basis, there is the OTC
buy-side liquidity on the right.
So, you can view this as a check on how much Bitcoin is being accumulated in over-the-counter trading.
Uh, last time,
that was in the early to mid-2024.  If
you look at the red, yellow, and orange boxes on the left in 2024, you can see a pattern where
liquidity flowed into the virtual asset market or
risk asset market as over-the-counter trading became active whenever there were fluctuations.
However,
since October 2025, you
can observe that such an inflow of liquidity is not currently visible whenever there is a decline
.  So, while it is currently
rising,
rather than viewing this upward momentum as a hint or evidence of active accumulation, you
should keep in mind that technical factors such as short covering may be more significant.  So, the
point I wanted to make is that, due to the
risk asset market and the spread across the entire sector,
such things have
not yet turned over somewhat within the overall stock market.  So, I
prepared this material to tell you that it wasn't quite right.
I think I can say it this way, as it is particularly specific in the margin market.
Oh, and there is exactly one
quarter left until the promised October.  Since we are about 75%
done, it's been about 91 days, so there are exactly
three months left.  I brought this much
to take right now
.  That's all.
thank you  When we look at excessive stock price drops, if the
price falls too sharply, we
examine the price, valuation, and support levels. However,
along with that, when the decline has widened significantly, people often say that a
true bottom is reached when there is a surge in trading volume. Is that correct
?
This is proof that there are many investors who think, "I really have to buy here
."  However, I
think you mentioned that those things are not visible right now
in the last table.   Yes, I
mentioned that even though there was an increase, it wasn't because of that.   hmm.
So,
looking at supply and demand and trading volume, as long as it holds a certain support level for the time being until the promised October,
yes.
We can continue to promise the October of promise
.
you're right.
[Laughs] Okay, I will wrap it up like that and
move on.
Uh, I'll be looking at the US market.  Today, since we need to look at the US
market and
things like valuations that are usually covered on Mondays, we typically
finish part of the session around 8 o'clock, but it may take a little longer than that
.   I will
listen carefully to the Vice President to hear about what other changes took place over the past week
.
yes.   The
US market was closed last Friday, but the
European market was open.  Looking at major European
stocks, they generally rose.   It
seems like IT stocks, mainly ASML, NXP Semiconductors, and Vessie, rose a bit.
Since the market was closed last Friday, you can consider this to be the US market price for four trading days
.   The
S&P 500 rose 1.8%, and
12-month forward EPS
was revised upward by 0.3%.   It
went up 9.3% year-to-date, but
ah, it's a bit difficult to achieve double-digit growth
.   The
12-month forward EPS
has been adjusted upward by 19.5%.
As of July 2, the
forward PR is trading at 20.19 times and the
PBR is trading at 5.74 times
.
Looking at the fluctuations last week, the
S&P 500 rose 1.8%, and
most of that contribution came from Big Tech.
Nvidia rose 1.2% and Apple 8.8%
.  Google fell 6.7%,
Microsoft 4.7%,
Amazon 4.3%, and
Broadcom 1.3%.
Meta rose 5.9%.  Tesla also
rose 3.6% for the first time in a while.
Aside from that, Mycon Technology
fell 13.8%, and
among the top 30 by market capitalization,
all semiconductor indices and semiconductor stocks
declined.  If you look at the red line at the bottom,
Micron and
Intel also fell by about 6.2%.
AMD also fell 3.8%, and Lam Research
fell 7.3%.  If you look at the YTD next to it, you can see that there have
generally been gains of over three digits.
However, regarding this significant rise, an issue related to the meta emerged last week that could serve as a pretext for a
rotation and help alleviate the concentration of investment
.  Ah, you can consider that as the result of that
.
Ah, Berkshire Hathaway rose 1.8%, and just like
us, financial stocks in the U.S. have been
rising somewhat in the short term recently
.  JPMorgan rose 1.6%
,
while Walmart fell 3.3%
.  If you look at the earnings side, well, there has
n't been any major change, but it
looks like a steady upward adjustment, and Micron Technology
has been raised by another 2.1%.   As you
will see later, it was observed that the profit estimates for Hynix and
Samsung Electronics were also
raised on a weekly basis.
If you look at the PR, the situation has dropped significantly.
Nvidia is at 18.4x and Apple is at
32.7x. Until recently,
Google was right
behind Nvidia, and there was
talk about whether it would take the top spot, but
Alphabet has fallen behind a bit.
Meanwhile, Apple has regained the second-place
position in market capitalization.  And
Microsoft is trading at about 20 times,
Amazon at 22.3 times, and
Broadcom has dropped to 21.5 times
.
And Meta 15x, Tesla
117.5x,
Eli Lilly 30x,
Micron Technology 7x, and
Berkshire Hathaway 25.7x, JP
Morgan 14.5x.
Overall,
uh, including the big tech companies and top-tier stocks by market capitalization, it
feels like their valuations have been downgraded a bit.
However, in the case of Apple, well, it is currently trading at 30 times its value
.
Ah, looking at sector trends, uh,
Consumer Discretionary, Healthcare, and Communications—with
large-cap stocks at the center—
contributed to the performance.  And on the other hand, the
Philippine index, energy, and real estate
underwent adjustments.  The Philippine Index, ah,
fell about 4.4% last week.  Uh, it has
dropped by about 11.4% this month.   You can
consider the EPS to be continuously being adjusted upward
.
Ah, if you look at the economic indicators, the
ISM services PMI, the
FOMC minutes, and the weekly
employment figures are coming out this week. I'm not sure if there will be a message in the FOMC minutes that will give us a sense of the
tone, but it is
scheduled for the 9th.
If you look at their earnings, they aren't particularly large stocks,
but you can consider Levi's,
PepsiCo, and Delta to be the
companies we are familiar with
.   In the
other sectors, Hynix's ADR listing is
scheduled for July 10.  Ah,
of course, Samsung Electronics' preliminary earnings announcement is also
scheduled for tomorrow.  And with
TSMC's June revenue
coming out this week, the second-quarter revenue is expected to be finalized.
For reference, the market consensus for the second-quarter revenue is
set at $39.6 billion.   It is an
increase of about 10.4% QOQ and 30.6% YOY
.
Looking at interest rates, the U.S. 10-year yield
rose 11 basis points to 4.48%, and the
2-year yield rose 5 basis points to
4.14%, with the
yield spread recording 35 basis points
.
This 10-year inflation is recording around
2.23%, up 3 basis points,
and the real interest rate is
recording around 2.24%, up 8 basis points.   The
high yield rose by about 3bp to
6.28%.   The
high-yield spread is recording
2.75%, down about 8 basis points from last week
.  So, overall, as
nominal interest rates rose slightly last week
, they are now approaching 4.55%
.
Next week, the CPI will be released, and
this week, it seems likely that there could be
some signals regarding prices from the ISM services sector
.
Looking at the commodities market, oil prices
fell by about 0.7% last week to
$68.76.
Copper rose 0.4% to
$6.17.
U.S. natural gas fell 1.1% to
$3.24, while
European natural gas rose 10.3%
in just one week. Although it is a rebound from the bottom, it is
said that demand for electricity for cooling is surging in Europe as the heatwave continues.   For
that reason, I
recorded 45.34 euros.
Looking at the foreign exchange market, the dollar index
fell 0.5% to
100.86.   The
dollar-won fell 0.4% to
1,529.2 won,
and the euro-dollar
recorded 1.143 dollars per euro;   The
dollar-yen exchange rate fell 0.23% to
161.37 yen
.  Therefore, as the dollar index
fell slightly, a
trend of major currencies strengthening slightly
was observed.
If you look at the KOSPI stock price, it has
fallen by about 3.8% over the past week.  The 12-month forward
EPS has been revised upward by about 4.5% and
is up 91.9% year-to-date.
With the 12-month forward EPS revised upward by 167.6%, the
increase in EPS this year is substantial.
As of July 3, the
KOSPI PER is 7.25 times and the PBR is
2.3 times
.
Four stocks—Samsung Electronics, SK Hynix, SK Square, and Samsung Electro-Mechanics—
declined. While the degree of decline may vary,
looking at the year-to-date figures, you can
view this as a correction following triple-digit drops
.   As for the
others,
Samsung Life Insurance fell 143% this year, but
fell 11.4% last week and is currently
up 143%; SK
fell 15% but rose 169%
year-on-
year and year-to-date; and
LG Electronics fell 2.5% but is currently
up about 107%.
Next, uh,
among the stocks that rose last week,
Hyundai Motor rose 2.4%, LG Ensol 9.4%,
and
uh, Samsung Biologics 5.8%, and Hanaro Aerospace
rose 16.2%.  Hyundai Heavy Industries
rose 2.3%.
If you look at earnings, Samsung Electronics and SK Hynix
were revised upward by 3.6% and 3.9%, respectively.  SK Square
was revised upward by 6.1% and Samsung Electro-Mechanics by 5.1% and
5.0%, but
despite the drop in stock prices
, earnings estimates continue to be revised upward;
currently, Samsung Electronics
is trading at 5.7 times its 12-month forward PR, and
SK Hynix is ​​trading at 6.2 times
.
Ah, other SK Square
is trading at 5.5 times its level.  Samsung Electro-Mechanics is
trading at 75.8x, Hyundai Motor at 10.5x, LG Ensol at 96.1x, Samsung Life Insurance at 26.1x, Samsung C&T at 23.3x, Samsung Biologics at 32.6x, Hanaro Aerospace at 23.3x, and Hyundai Heavy Industries at 18x.
Domestic interest rates have also risen slightly, with the 10-year yield
increasing by 8 basis points to 4.2% and the
3-year yield increasing by 3 basis points to
3.75%, while the yield spread
remains at 45 basis points.
Investor deposits
dropped quite a bit last week.   It is
119.9 trillion, down about 7 trillion,
and credit loans are 37.7 trillion, down about 400 billion
.
Ah, the weekly average daily trading volume also
recorded 50.1 trillion, a decrease of 10 trillion.  So,
reflecting the somewhat slow market atmosphere last week, the
funds surrounding the stock market were also moving a bit slowly
.   There are
no specific macroeconomic indicators this week, but there are expected to be variables
in the domestic market such as
Samsung Electronics' earnings announcement, the
flow of SK Hynix's ADR listing,
and TSMC's performance. These will help us
check whether the semiconductor sector can reverse the trend after undergoing a correction for about two weeks, so it would be good to
keep a close eye on those aspects.   That's
all.  thank you  It's been a while, so I'm going through the
valuation-related indicators that the Vice President goes over every Monday
.  I will just ask up to this point and
move on.  First of all, on the
very first page,
you provided a valuation based on the US market S&P 500, with a
PER of 20.1 times and a PBR of
5.74.
Of course, when looking at U.S. market valuations,
we need to consider interest rate levels and the overall
direction—whether the economy is currently in an uptrend
or downtrend—but
intuitively, if the S&P 500
valuation is below 20 times, it seems to have
always been a buying zone over the past 5 to 10 years
.
So, regarding ROE levels, book
value levels, and things like that, if we delve into the discussion,
interpretations may vary from time to time.
However, since the S&P 500 is at a level of about 20 times,
while stocks related to the Philadelphia Semiconductor Index
showed tremendous volatility, the
reason the US market index remained relatively calm in the broader context was explained here
.  Yes, that is correct.
Ah, the Peel Semiconductor Index accounts for about 15% of the total U.S.
market.
Could you pick out one or two sectors where profits are growing steadily but the multiples seem to have been significantly adjusted?
Uh, well,
uh, in the field of communication, uh, right now
Google,
yes.
Ah, it's
trading at 24x, and
Meta is trading at 15x.   hmm.
Uh, actually
, in the case of Meta, well, when it comes to
profit growth rates or revenue growth rates, there is
n't really anything particularly bad compared to other stocks in other sectors.  However, as you know, with the
continued aggressive growth of captives, the
market is saying that free cash flow will drop, decrease, or even turn negative, and
currently,
trading is taking an excessive 15x turnover.  Then,
excluding Meta and the free cash flow portion, do
other companies with similar strength to Meta receive a 15x leverage
?  That's not the case.
That's true.
yes.  So, I think that
in this specific AI cycle, this part is currently
undervalued or the valuation is significantly
suppressed.
And regarding other specific areas,
uh,
in the US market, if you look at the
S&P
500, AI currently accounts for about half of the market in some way, whether it be
infrastructure, software, hardware, or
semiconductors
.   yes
.   The
old economy sectors that are not like that
account for about half.  If
we look at it that way, rather than saying one
side is overvalued or undervalued, I
think that contrasting performances driven by AI momentum will likely continue.
So, stocks with significant momentum in the AI ​​sector can
continue to perform well compared to those that are not
.  Otherwise,
even if the stocks on the opposite side, the BAI side, have good fundamentals, are cheap, and have attractive valuations, if they lag slightly behind in terms of momentum, I
think their stock prices might be neglected for a while.  So, if you look closely at the US market,
there are situations where valuations are emphasized or old-economy stocks are highlighted, and the times when such stocks stand out are during crisis situations, you know.  For example, like during the dot-com bubble
.
Ah, or maybe
during the 2008 financial crisis, or when interest
rates spiked significantly and the Fed
aggressively raised rates to curb inflation like in 2022—in
those cases, those stocks—ah, currently
[clears throat]
have very robust cash flow and the strength to maintain their valuations, so they
show considerably solid performance compared to growth stocks that are not like that. However, under normal circumstances,
in the US market,
earnings momentum is more important than valuation.  And it seems that stock prices tend to differentiate
depending on how strong the future growth momentum is
.
I also agree with Eco.
If institutional investors investing in the U.S. market
choose value stocks—or what could be called low-beta stocks—rather than growth stocks, it seems they could find
many such options in other developed markets as well
.  I think that might be because valuations in Europe and places like that are
much lower
.
Looking at the major companies announcing earnings here,
things like Delta and PepsiCo relate to
overall economic conditions or consumer
sentiment. As for
Levi's... ah,
Levi's...
[laughs] For
my generation, it's still...
ah, yes, yes... but since it's a
somewhat familiar name, I'll take a look. I've noted it down. Also, I wonder if there was any
deeper significance to it.
And below
[clears throat] regarding
US interest rates, the difference between long-term and short-term yields, and the high-yield spread, since
we check the US
10-year and 2-year Treasury yields
every day, I
think we are discussing the fundamentals and sentiment on a case-by-case basis. Aside from that, regarding
various long-term indicators or trends related to interest rates, I
think we can just move on assuming there are no specific issues.
Oil prices didn't fall that much last week. With a
rapid drop of 0.7%, it seemed as though
US Treasury yields were shifting downwards in line with the speed of the decline in oil prices, which had previously stimulated inflation, but that
slowed down a bit last week.
And if you
think about it carefully, what stimulates inflation is the
supply side, such as oil prices.
There are factors driving up costs, but there are also demand factors.
So, I
think the current situation is one where demand factors could also stimulate prices to some extent. While there are consumption
factors,
consumer sentiment hasn't been particularly strong recently.
Also,
looking at the
first-quarter GDP, the major contributor to it was private
investment—specifically corporate investment—rather than consumption. Therefore, I
suspect that this aspect remains a factor that could stimulate interest rates.
So
, as Byeoljubu
mentioned,
since the US-Iran war, the contribution of energy prices
to the CPI has exceeded 1%
.  Because the
CPI rose from the 2% level
to 4.2%, and if we
break that down, energy
contributed about 1.5 percentage points
.  So, I don't know how much that 1.5%p will
decrease over time, but if that part
peaks out, I
think the inflationary pressure from cost-increasing factors might subside a bit
.  At the same time, uh, personally, I think it might be difficult for the
10-year U.S. Treasury yield to go further up from here
.  yes.   Since the
Vice President always checks everything meticulously, I will just
[snort] it as I look at it
.  He
told me that, and looking at the domestic market,
well, regarding
the US, I don't know if it's because I've become so absorbed in the Vice President's words,
but he explained the S&P
500 index and, when
doing valuation,
for example, saying the index is this much and the S&P
500's EPS
is $360,
so the P/E ratio is this many times.  This
way of explaining things sounds very familiar, but I do
n't think I've really heard that kind of explanation in Korea. However, while
reading through domestic strategy data last weekend, I heard people saying that
Korea's KOSPI EPS is 1,200
won or 1,100 won, implying
that the
multiple has now dropped
to the low 7s, the lowest level since the financial crisis
.  Well,
seeing you say that, I thought, "Ah, so now there are
people in Korea explaining the KOSPI using EPS," but has it actually
been that long already—did I just get
lazy and only see this now?
Ah, this is
[clears throat] well, in the
case of our country,
um, there are many conglomerates, you know.   There are
also many holding companies.
So,
the US has a style of simply listing companies that focus solely on their core business as single entities, without holding companies or conglomerates
.  So, the
process itself, from operating profit to net profit and EPS, is simple.  But
[clears throat] as you know, Mr.
Representative, in the case of our country, if
a company holds about 20% or 30%,
that is processed through consolidation so it
appears as if they hold 100% initially,
yes, initially, and as you go down
to the bottom line, only that shareholding amount is reflected, right?
So
, personally, I think that in some aspects, it is
correct to evaluate it at the bottom line
.  Because when we look at operating profit, if we consider the
equity method—oh, in the
case of consolidated companies, they just use 100% of the operating profit
.  That is why
, personally, I think there might be some distortion.
So, for
whatever reason, in the
case of Warren Buffett, he argues that the further
down you go, the
more explanatory power the operating profit side has compared to the bottom line, due to temporary factors such as non-operating income
.  So, even though operating profit is a really
good indicator, I believe it
becomes somewhat distorted when there are many companies consolidating. In that
sense, I think looking at EPS is a bit
more appropriate for a country like Korea, but I'm not sure
.
Depending on the perspective, if our stock market or
economy moves toward a developed-country model, the
KOSPI is currently trading at several times its EPS, following the American style.  I think this
kind of explanation will become more common in the future, but
personally,
I
think evaluating it in that way is a natural direction.
thank you  Warren, what do you call
that operating profit increase
?  If
you had known that some parts were exaggerated, you might have said it a little differently
.
Yes, that is correct.
yes.  It would be a better suggestion if Korea also gradually
changed its accounting standards like this and improved them so that they could be compared equally with the U.S.   I came to realize while
reviewing the data over the past weekend that, although Korean interest rates are not currently rising to the point where an increasing number of commercial banks are offering rates of 3% or higher on domestic 1-year fixed deposits, market rates have already begun to significantly reflect this
.
Looking at it so far today, yes, that is correct
yes.  Thanks to you for explaining things so thoroughly; I
received a lot of help from you today as well.
Today, I covered the valuations for Monday
and the overall stock market conditions for major countries, including Korea and the US.
Now, in the second part, we will take a direct look at the Korean market,
and I expect the Executive Director will answer the key questions in a
Q&A session with the Vice President
.  Part 1 was a bit
long today.
Thank you to everyone at Channelton for joining us, and we will see you again shortly in Part 2
.  thank you
thank you   hmm.
[Music]
Hmm.   hmm.
Hello.  We will now begin Part 2 of the "Happy Investment Journey"
Choi Seul-li Investment
Choi Seul-li Morning Brief for today, Monday, July 6th
.
It seems like the rainy season is late.   It did
n't rain in June, then in July, it
rained gently, and then poured down again,
right?   yes
.   It is
very good.   I
rarely wash my car.   yes
.
So, since it rains like this, I intentionally
parked my car outside to get a
wash, and then later in the afternoon while playing
soccer, a sudden downpour
came down, which was nice and refreshing
.   With its
distinct four seasons and abundant rain,
our country
seems to be a truly blessed nation.
Now, I’m going to review last Friday’s market, and I
listened to this Tale of the Turtle and the Turtle again on my way here this morning.   yes
.   It was really
good to listen on Saturday.
Chief Choi came on again and gave us a stream of
priceless comments. I
heard all the details about that fund manager, ah, the JP Morgan "Guide to the Market to the Market." Also, since he gave a great
summary of the week on *Byeoljubujeon*, I was thinking, "Oh, that's right." But on my way here in
the morning, I felt like I had forgotten a bit, so I
listened to *Byeoljubujeon* one more time.
Now, regarding the domestic market... Section
Chief Oh will take care of it.
Yes [clears throat]
I will give you the Friday market report.   The
KOSPI index rose with a somewhat strong rebound of 5.7%, while the
KOSDAQ
closed flat.  So, it
seems that on Friday, the market showed signs of falling a bit during the morning session before rebounding sharply.
In terms of supply and demand, individual investors have
injected over 6 trillion won in buying pressure.   On
the other hand, there was a sell-off of 4.4 trillion won by foreign investors
.   There
was about 2 trillion won in selling from institutions, and
strong buying pressure of over 3 trillion won flowed into foreign futures
.
Looking at trading trends by investor type,
it appears that foreign investors showed strong buying interest in the IT substrate sector, which had fallen significantly recently, as they purchased Samsung Electro-Mechanics, Daeduck Electronics, LG Innotek, HPSP, Hyundai Motor, and Hyundai Mobis.   Regarding
foreign selling, they sold approximately 1.7 trillion won in SK Hynix and
380 billion won in Samsung Electronics; while they had
recently been selling around 3 to 4 trillion won,
it seems the scale of the selling itself is decreasing.
Other than that, I sold Jusung Engineering,
SK Square, LS Elect
Isu Peta, Hyosung Heavy Industries,
HD Hyundai Electric, etc.
It seems that institutional buying was quite strong, with around 2.5 trillion won in SK Hynix and 1.3 trillion won in Samsung Electronics.  Other than that, I purchased KB Financial Group,
Electronic Preferred Stock,
Hanwha Aerospace, SK Square, etc.   It
appears that while institutions sold off Samsung Electro-Mechanics, Daeduck Electronics, and LG Innotek, they focused their buying more on the printed circuit board (PCB) sector.   There were only
three stocks that hit a 52-week high
.
There was one stock on the KOSPI, Kolmar Korea.  On the KOSDAQ, Intech Plus and
Geo Element hit
new highs.
Yes, looking at Kolmar Korea, since
Hamburger has been covering it so well
, when you usually trade stocks and monitor those that rise significantly on a weekly basis, you tend to
just keep looking at the stocks you own
and
don't pay attention when other stocks go up
.   I
don't end up looking at it.  Because cognitive biases are
ingrained in our bodies, I really enjoyed
reading *The Tale of the Turtle and the Rabbit*.  That American
company Moderna, and
what was the other one?
Of the two, they were both Palantir.
Ah,Palantir.
yes.  I didn't buy either of them last week.
[Laughs] We
talked about it, and later, seeing you discuss various
toys and things based on that, uh, it was really
nice to see.
So, while watching, I also had various opinions,
um.
Ah, so these stocks are
circulating again on a weekly basis.
But a brief rebound amidst a downtrend is
always a [clearing one's throat]
.
Then, is it just a temporary rebound?   In the
case of Moderna, it looks like they are
turning around in a meaningful way.   You
can see what kind of momentum is driving the stock price up like that, and
among Korean companies, like Kolmar Korea and Pumptech Korea in the
cosmetics sector, as I was watching the story of Byeoljubujeon, I thought, "Have they
already gone up this much?"  You're
saying he's fifty?
So,
actually, [snorting] it
all came out in the June export data as well
.   It's
number one in semiconductors, and
yes.
Then, looking at it, cosmetics
exports were also quite good. However, as I
mentioned,
since semiconductors increased by 200%, the 200%
or 30% growth in other sectors is
n't very visible; but it seems the sectors that are going to keep rising
.
So, I
learned a lot as well.
[Clears throat]
But foreigners
hit Hynix for 1.755 trillion won.
Why are you hitting me like this?
So,
there is an ADR listing this week, too.
Yes, well, the scale of selling itself is decreasing,
but it
still seems to be somewhat of a selling bias
. And as we have always said, because the weight of Samsung Electronics and SK Hynix in the portfolio is becoming so high, the stock price rise was stronger no matter how much we sold.
yes.
That is why I
think selling pressure is still emerging.
It looks like the shareholding has now dropped below 50%.
Yes.  you're right.   yes
.  In some places, they even
said it was an empty house.  If you
look solely at the foreign buying volume,
hitting this level is
yes.   yes.
Uh, well, yeah.   So, there
was some selling by foreign investors in Samsung Electronics and SK Hynix, while institutions
aggressively bought Samsung Electronics and SK Hynix again
.  Right?
Now, let's take a look at the trends of the major stocks
.  I was talking about bullish beekeeping on Friday, and it
rose sharply.   I
didn't expect it to go up this much.
So, lately, I’ve been saying the
exact same thing last time—that
pattern where a long bearish candle appears, followed by buying rebound the next day only for it to fall again—and after I mention that, a bullish
candle always follows.  Actually, the market rolled back up
in the afternoon, so
my prediction was wrong.
Well, let's
take a look at the stock trends.   I
think the rebound was strong because the stock price had fallen significantly despite Samsung Electronics' earnings announcement being scheduled for this week and the upcoming momentum from SK Hynix's ADR listing on July 10th
.   If we
look at the semiconductor sector first,
Samsung Electronics surged 8% in the large semiconductor sector, and
SK Hynix
recorded a significant increase of about 11%.   The
semiconductor materials, parts, and equipment sector was generally
good, though.
HPSP showed a sharp rise of about 11%
.  Reno Industrial and
EOTech closed up approximately 4.6%
.  Well, aside from that, the
equipment stocks below were generally good as well.
In particular,
I think it was notable that the ISC showed a rebound of about 8% for the first time in a while.
Also, since there may be some expectations for Samsung Electronics' foundry business in the second half of the year, it
seems that companies like Doosan Tes are receiving some attention recently.
In the IT sector, Samsung Electro-Mechanics
closed up about 3%.
LG Electronics and LG Innotek also
showed weakness.
And
BH and Fine M-Tech in the mobile value chain below also showed a strong upward trend
.
Since Apple's new iPhone is scheduled to be released in the second half of the year, and a foldable iPhone is also expected to be released, I
think it is worth looking forward to the stock price of Fine M-Tech, which manufactures internal hinges, in the second half of the year.   The
platform sector
showed a slightly sluggish trend compared to the market.  The Nikkei
index managed to rebound by about 1.5%, but it
seemed a bit weaker than the domestic market.  Tokyo Electronics
recorded a growth rate of about flat, and with Murata
rising by 1.9%, Hoya by 1.3%, and Advantes by about 1.8%, the semiconductor equipment and
substrate sectors were not bad.
Oh, the automotive sector also rebounded, albeit slightly
.  Hyundai closed up 2%,
Kia 4.7%, and Mando about 4%
.
Looking at recent reports, there is a lot of talk that Hyundai Motor will perform
well in terms of vehicle sales and earnings.
However, since the rise in the stock price was
not driven by the automobile business, this is not currently
being reflected in the stock price
.
Looking at the consumer sector,
Life Health & Health Care remained flat,
while Amore rose 1.5%, marking its second consecutive day of gains
.  So, it's not bad even on a one-month
basis
.  It is currently rising by about 10 to 11%
.  Cosmecca Korea
closed down about 2.5%.
Below that, the skin care device sector
was generally weak, with the exception of Wontech.
Classys, Pharmaresearch, and Shugel
generally showed an APR of 3%
.
Oh, and in the food and beverage sector below,
Nongshim and Samyang Foods
have gone back into negative territory.
Department store chains and duty-free shops also performed poorly, with
Shinsegae and Hyundai Department Store falling by 3% each
.
If you look at the shipbuilding, steel, and other sectors, Hanwha
Ocean fell 2.2%, while
Hanwha Ocean still closed up about 2.3%
.   The
steel and chemical sectors
fluctuated fairly evenly, and looking
down at the defense stocks,
Hanwha Aerospace rose 5.3% and
Dexton rose 5.1%;
it seems they rose quite significantly, especially last week.  Securities stocks also started to rebound.
Uh, they had fallen quite a bit recently, so their
valuation appeal also showed a strong upward trend
in Friday's market.   The
entertainment sector generally
appeared to turn somewhat weak in the Friday market.   The
transformer sector recorded a decline of around 2%
.
Yes, but looking at this overall
trend chart of major stocks,
everything was really red like this last week or so, but
the area where you can faintly see a slight red tint is the consumer goods sector
.   It's
getting a little red.
Uh, looking at the bottom, there is a slight feeling that the shipbuilding, steel,
chemical, energy, defense, aviation, pharmaceutical, bio,
finance, and entertainment sectors are also getting a bit brighter again
.
Okay, so we've looked at the trends of the major stocks.
Uh, you brought a
report on the paradox of stock prices—why is it
being so neglected?
What are the conditions for a rebound?
Uh, that’s how all of
SK Jangnyeom-in’s research portfolios are.   I'm
curious too.  Seriously, why am I so
alienated?   Since
securities stocks have been rebounding recently, I
brought some portfolio items.
High transaction volume and performance.  However, it is said to be an
undervalued stock.  Despite unprecedented
index gains and the
era of 100 trillion won in average daily trading volume, stock prices in the securities sector have been
significantly sluggish.   It is
said that, similar to the Cha-Hwa-Jeong rally of 2011, a paradoxical phenomenon is emerging where securities stocks are being neglected despite the bullish stock market and surge in trading volume, due to concentration in specific areas.
Uh, since 2000, in bull markets,
excluding supply and demand imbalances, it has been
somewhat rare for securities stocks to fall before trading volume.   That's what they say
.
Considering the correlation between trading volume and securities stocks, and given that the current average daily trading volume is
increasing quarter-on-quarter, we
assess that securities stocks are not yet in a phase of a significant, leading decline.
Well, while being left out in a semiconductor-led market is
unavoidable, there is an opinion that if rotation trading
occurs, it might be time to pay attention to securities stocks once again
.
Ultimately, the opinion is that the extent of trading volume expansion will likely
act as a key variable for securities stocks in the future
.   yes
.
There are also concerns in the market recently regarding a peak in trading volume.   It is said that
new catalysts are needed for securities stocks. While the
slowdown in trading volume growth, which is a concern in the market, is
projected to be somewhat inevitable, it is reported that there are several
factors that could offset concerns about a peak-out
.
Uh, the first one is ETF growth.   It is said that
ETF trading volume has been increasing even more rapidly since the launch of single-stock leveraged ETFs, but
trading volume is not the only point worth noting
.  It is said that the landscape of market share, which had been
firmly maintained in the existing securities industry, is shifting somewhat following the launch of single-stock leverage ETFs
.
Uh, thanks to the DMA service,
Korea Investment & Securities' ETF market share has
risen significantly recently, and it
maintained it this time as well.  Both stocks have
high profit contributions from the brokerage and asset management sectors, and also offer some value merit
.  In addition, Korea Financial Holdings
can also benefit from valuation gains on its subsidiaries' securities due to the strong stock market.  I've
done this much.
[Clears throat]
Now, if you look down at the table below, it is
said that trading volume, the KOSPI index, and the trends in securities stocks all moved in tandem.   The
current market sentiment suggests that this
growth may slow down.   The
transaction amount itself.  However, the researcher's
opinion is that even if the growth rate itself
declines, there is still a possibility that this amount will be maintained or even
rise,
so concerns about a peak-out are a bit premature
.  On the right is the
market share trend of Universe Securities' KRX NXT ETF
.
Certainly, Mirae Asset Securities
saw its stock price surge due to the momentum of the SpaceX listing, but
actually, it had started to decline even before the listing took place
.   As the
momentum materialized, sell-ons
began to appear somewhat early, and it
seems that this trend has continued until recently.  In fact,
in terms of valuation, Mirae Asset’s stock price
decline seems to have been more significant because, due to the momentum from the SpaceX listing, its PBR had risen to three times, far exceeding even the high valuations previously viewed by securities firms.   As for the
remaining stocks, well, although they
traded at a higher rate compared to their previous PBR multiples
, the levels themselves
weren't particularly high, so they
seem to have performed relatively well.
Below that, the first purple one
is Kiwoom.   The
yellow one is Korea Financial Holdings.   The
light blue line represents the PBR valuation trend of Samsung Securities
.
Samsung Securities has risen quite a bit recently, so it has
surpassed the valuation of Kiwoom Securities.  So,
among these three companies
,
Samsung Securities is currently trading at the highest forward PBR multiple at 1.1 times
.  Next is Kiwoom Securities at about
1x.
And Korea Financial Holdings is
yellow and is trading at about 0.9 times
.  Actually, if we
consider attractiveness in terms of market conditions and market share, wouldn't
Korea Financial Holdings have the potential to reach a higher valuation than Samsung—ah, Kiwoom Securities
?
Looking at this chart, I did have that thought a little.   hmm.
You're right, now that I look at it.  hmm.
But regarding
this share based on total trading volume, it is strange
how ETFs lean toward K-Investment.
As of June,
K-Investment's share of universe securities ETF trading volume is 26.7%
.   yes
.
I think Hanwha was the ace.
But that Kiwoom thing is
Korean
.
ah.
That is indeed Hanwha Investment & Securities Asset Management
.
That is what is being operated.
Yes, that's right.
This is the total trading volume of all ETFs traded on the securities market
.   hmm.
That Codex is managed by Samsung Asset Management.
Yes, that iscorrect.
But
right now, that is not ETF market share, but
ETF trading volume share.
So, it seems we should view this as customers using Korea Investment & Securities
particularly engaging in a significant amount of ETF trading
.
Yes, that is the case on the surface.
yes.   I heard that Korea
Investment & Securities has introduced a DMA system
.
What is that?   It was a
term I had never heard before, so I looked it up and
found out that it is an order method where
customer orders are connected directly to the exchange without going through HTS or MTS
.  So, it is
said to be a very meaningful program for ultra-short-term traders, algorithmic traders, and program traders, and I heard that Korea Investment &
Securities recently introduced it.
ah.
So, with
many ETFs and leveraged ETFs
listed and market volatility increasing,   hmm.
As a result, as far as I know, many ultra-short-term traders
use Kiwoom Securities
.   hmm.   I wonder if
that market share has shifted a bit, yes, towards Korea Investment & Securities
?   uh
.
Yes, you could think that way
Manager Shingu, have you ever heard of something like that
?
When I did it,
there were those internet brokerage firms, you know, rather than that.  With Toss Bank and similar players
rising significantly,
I am looking at the data right now, and
Kiwoom Securities' market share has dropped below 25%.  But when I was
watching Kiwoom Securities for a while, I remember it going up by about 30% to 40%. While there may
be various reasons, I thought the
rise in Toss Securities stock was quite significant
.
But regarding this DMA service,
there actually are options that make it easier to trade things like 2x leveraged ETFs.   When
we were doing institutional trading, back when
I was heavily involved in derivatives trading, we used to wonder
which side was a little faster.  That's
0.1.
It's not like it's almost a 1-second difference, 0.1. It's just a few seconds
difference,
hmm.
So, there were some places saying that the execution was a bit faster, so I guess it's kind of
that concept, right?
It seems like it's a bit faster due to the DMA concept.   I will look into
that part a bit more and let you know
tomorrow.
So, what Researcher Jang is saying is that,
excluding supply and demand imbalances in bull markets since 2000, there have
been no instances where securities stocks fell before
trading volume. Furthermore,
considering the correlation between trading volume and securities stocks, the point is that this is not a phase where securities stocks should be falling like this, given that the
current average daily trading volume is steadily
increasing
.   While being
left out in a semiconductor-led market is
inevitable,
if rotation occurs, it might be worth
paying attention to securities stocks once again
.   That is the gist of it.
Below,
one of the new factors is ETF growth, followed by
expectations for policies in the second half of the year. As
for preferred stocks, they mentioned Korea Financial Holdings and
Samsung Securities
.
And as shown in the table below,
Mirae Asset Securities
[clears throat]
raised the possibility of lowering memory package substrate prices in the second half of the year, causing the stock prices of
memory package substrate
manufacturers such as Daeduck Electronics, Simtek, and Haesung DS to undergo a significant correction last week
.
Uh, however, with
growing concerns about the supply and demand of package substrates in the second half of 2026, I believe that
memory IDMs recording high profit margins have
somewhat limited incentive to lower package substrate prices.  This
week's correction should actually be viewed as a strong buying opportunity
.
On the contrary, concerns about supply shortages are growing
.   In
April and May of 2026, the overall selling price of memory package
substrates was increased to reflect the rise in raw material prices for gold and copper
.  It is estimated that the price hike reflects not only simple
cost increases but also,
in part, the possibility of tight supply in the second half of the year
.   It is
said that the production capacity of memory package substrate manufacturers has virtually stagnated since large-scale expansions in 2020 and 2022.
On the other hand, while the main products at the time were DDR4 and
LPDDR4, it is
said that the actual capacity itself is decreasing as the focus shifts to DDR5, LPDDR5, and 5X, and as the PCB area becomes larger and multi-layered.
You can view this in the same context as how memory manufacturers reduced their actual wafer production volume as they heavily utilized their capacity for HBM.   It is said that
the increase in memory performance and the expansion of die sizes are
accelerating capacity erosion
.   As
leading companies such as Taiwan's Unimicron and Samsung Electro-Mechanics are focusing on
expanding into the highly profitable flip-chip BJ sector, the
global BT
substrate industry's
supply capacity is becoming increasingly limited
.   It is said that
in the second half of 2026, NVIDIA Rubin plans to
expand the supply of general memory, and Chinese memory
manufacturers are scheduled to increase DDR5 shipments
.  It is the opinion that in the mid-to-long term,
aggressive capacity expansion by the three memory companies is
expected, and the
demand for memory package substrates is
highly likely to continue increasing.
Therefore, it is assessed that the possibility of a supply shortage for memory package substrates is also
increasing
.   The
shortage signal can be viewed through the LTA,
and it is said that
the status of the LTA connection is considered the most important signal regarding whether there is a shortage of the package substrate
.  It is said that in March 2020,
Simtek signed a large-scale supply contract worth over 100 billion won with Micron, and that this was an
exceptionally large
contract given the industry's short lead times for memory package substrates.  It is said that since then, the actual
supply shortage intensified and the price increase
cycle began in earnest
.  Considering the current global supply and
demand situation for circuit boards, the opinion is that a
similar trend could appear in the second half of 2026
.
The recent
stock price correction of memory package substrate manufacturers should be utilized as a buying opportunity in the mid-to-long term
.   That's it
.
Recently, stocks like Daeduck, Simtek, Haesung, and
DS
did experience significant short-term declines.
On a monthly basis, Daeduck fell by about 17% and
Isu Petasis fell by 20%
.  Simtek was
relatively sturdy and
durable.  Although it plummeted on Thursday, it is currently
up about 23% on a monthly basis,
so I
think that among PCB manufacturers, companies like Daeduck Electronics are now in a situation where their valuation merit has increased
.  Below, the
order backlog trends for Simtek and Daeduck Electronics are displayed, and it is
clear that the flip-chip BJ sector is
showing shortages first.  As a result, the
order backlog for Daeduck Electronics, which is doing flip-chip BJ, is filling up more rapidly
.
I think I'll be able to see it.  In fact, regarding Simtek, the
additional momentum we can see here
is the socket, so we can say that it is not yet present in the order
backlog as it is still a bit high
.
On the right is the performance trend of Simtek; as is the case
here as well, the high-value-added
sector always
recovers faster.  Daedeok Electronics is on
the right.
Currently, based on first-quarter earnings, the profit margin has
rapidly risen to the mid-10% range
.   In
the case of Simtek,
since it is recording an operating margin of about 3%, the
warmth has not yet spread to the legacy board sector
.  It doesn't seem to have spread completely
.   What
you are saying, Researcher, is that
Symtec had
even signed an LTA contract with Micron due to a past shortage, and
after that situation, price
increases appeared steeply.   That's what they said
.  If that happens, considering that
Symtec's
margins soared to almost 20% or even higher around 2022, it is
a bit difficult to expect that level since legacy PCBs aren't currently in
short supply like flip-chip BGAs. However, I
think we should leave open the possibility that margins could still rise to the mid-10% range.   For
Daeduck Electronics, the possibility has actually increased that the past cycle will
surpass the 22-year OP margin
.
Since they have largely shifted their business toward flip-chip BGA and are currently investing in MLB,
Daeduck Electronics
looks a bit better from that perspective, but it
seems their respective momentum is somewhat different.   I
was looking at the table below and comparing it with Simtek's stock price.
Since we are stock investors, we were wondering if the stock
moves according to earnings
or orders.
Looking at it, the trend in Simtek's order
backlog and the stock price trend are almost
identical.  Regarding the inflection point or similar
aspects, I heard that
Simtek
signed a large-scale supply contract worth over 100 billion won with Micron in March 2020.
However, considering that the entire world was under lockdown
due to COVID-19 in March 2020, I wonder just how
desperate they must have been to sign this, and I question whether it was actually
concluded. But looking at
Chart 3 on the left, which
shows the trend of Simtek's order backlog, and
seeing how the order backlog surged through the first and second quarters of 2020 during the pandemic, it does seem like the contract was indeed
signed.
Looking at it, that is correct.
After that, the order backlog continued to
grow steadily until early 2022, but the
stock price
peaked right in March 2022.   It
peaked in March 2022, and
looking at it, it dropped almost exactly in line with the downward trend in the order backlog.   In
early '24, when the order backlog
hit a slight upward trend,
there was a weak rebound—a slight, stumbling wave—from late '23 to early '4, but
looking at it, the stock price got completely wrecked in the second half of '24.   The
stock price, which was around 57,000 or 58,000 won,
has dropped to the 10,000 won range.   The
stock price has dropped 80%.   As it
plunged sharply into a deficit.
Ah, as we start running at a deficit.   After
falling, the
stock price rose rapidly recently along with an increasing trend in order backlog, and it has
now easily surpassed the high of 2022.
Compared to the peak of 164,200 won, it is
currently down 21% from the peak.   yes
.
Simtek was the
first thing I mentioned when Manager Oh was starting out
.   That is true, though
.   yes
.   I did
n't know it would count like this.  yes.
Because I didn't really know that the 'inner chem' would be significantly reflected in the increase like this.   Back then,
right when the rebound started, I was
talking about the internal chemistry.   yes
.
And
uh, an acquaintance of mine is
very close with Simtek
, and I also met the current president of Simtek once before, but
that was probably
10 or
15 years ago.
So, we invested heavily in Sok Chem, but the
market wasn't opening up. However, now that the
market has opened up
, our upfront investment in Kepa Sok Chem is
finally paying off.
Yes, they did mention that.   Well,
Nvidia just skipped the first game, you know.
Moving straight to Sok Chem 2.  I had
said that since what was released last year started with Internal Chem 1, Internal Chem chips would likely be recorded significantly starting from the first half of this year, but that got delayed.   hmm.
Because that part is scheduled to be equipped with Vera Rubin in the second half of this year and into next year.
That part.  But what was also
very significant for Symtek was that it was a
company that only did legacy work.
And as other legacy companies
transitioned to the flip-chip business,
companies like Daeduck Electronics saw their valuations rise and their
performance improve even
more when market conditions were good.  Since a
company that didn't used to make such an attempt is doing it, there's a bit of a
valuation re-rating,
hmm.   I scoff a bit at
the thought that what appeared was the main driving force behind the recent rise in Simtek's stock price.
So, looking here, will the order backlog
continue to rise this year and next?   Yes, I
think we entered a current trend where it is bound to go up. As we mentioned among ourselves last time,
earnings tend to lag behind memory stocks, and the
stock price tends to fall later as well.
So, looking at it from that perspective, I
think it is somewhat difficult to say that the circuit board is finished.   It's
down 35% from the peak.
Yes, it has dropped to the 5-month moving average on the monthly chart, and
uh, looking at past stock price trends, the
stock price tends to fall in tandem with the trend of order backlog and positive earnings
. This means that the earnings growth trend for this year and next year is bound to continue.
Yes, and since there hasn't been a significant price increase yet, if a
price hike does occur, as we
can see from the past trends of the office margin, the
current gains are actually just equivalent to the increase in the utilization rate
.  Uh, now that a
price hike is coming out, the likelihood of the office margin expanding has
increased.   hmm.   I'll have to watch
carefully.   It's
just that in the past, when adjustments were made, if one
side was adjusted so much, you'd think, "
Oh, really, ah, now that it's this much, hmm, is
n't it enough?"
right?   It
tends to go down to the second, third, or even fifth basement levels before coming back up,
so I think you need to carefully observe at
what point the volatility stops the correction before
investing
.
[Clears throat]
There was a long-term story here too, right?
This part
seems like it will be an important signal, and it is highly likely that
such a possibility will appear in the second half of this year
.   yes
.   I'm
talking about it.
All right.  I will take a good look.
Well, since we’ve already taken care of the US market ahead of the domestic market, we
have some spare time.   ruler.
What is the estimated market price
?
Yes, it is expected to rise by a plus 1.45%
.
Okay, the U.S. market
opens tonight, again.
Yes, it opens.
Uh, it's coming back up after a day and a half break, but looking at
past trends, I'm
not sure how the U.S. market performed after the Independence Day closure.  But
July wasn't bad.
ah.
Based on the date.   It was
n't bad by my standards, but
well, tomorrow morning it feels a
bit empty since our Yuri Pro isn't here,
yeah.
Who will cover the US market starting tomorrow morning
?
Our pro Chang-min Jang
has agreed to take charge.
Ah, Pro Chang-min Jang?
yes.   I
will take charge of this.
Then I guess I can ask Pro Chang-min Chang about the US
market tonight.
Yes, that is correct.   uh
.
Changmin Pro,
what do you think will happen in the US market tonight?
Tonight and last week,
there were concerns that there might be an oversupply of Cape X due to the Delta mutation, and as a result, the
semiconductor market
showed a somewhat excessive downward trend.
Yes, concerns about interest rate hikes
appear to have eased somewhat, and there is
also an opinion that this is a process of reallocating older capacity. Therefore, with the
overall rise in tech stocks, I expect both the S&P
500 and the market
to rise tonight.
Also, since
I stayed up all night on Sunday
creating materials with Pro Jang Min, it
seems we will be shortening the recommendation program by about 4:50 hours as well.   Then, should
we try the Dow forward?
[Clears throat]
What do you think will happen in the US market tonight
? Whether it's the Dow, the S&P 500, or the
Nasdaq,
I also think the
US market as a whole could rise today
.   I
think tech stocks fell a bit too excessively last week, so I
expect a positive trend to emerge now.
Okay, there is a really important part about the Nasdaq this week and next week,
um.
Uh, the Nasdaq isn't able to break through its high point right now
.
yes.
Right?
However, the Philippine Index broke through its high point,
broke through again at the beginning and end of the month, and then came back down.
Yes, that is correct.
Then, the recent phenomenon is that the Dow is
strong.   The
Dow is currently
rising while hitting new highs, and
this kind of pattern is actually
quite important because a similar phenomenon occurred at the end of
2021, right before the correction came in
.
So, at
the end of 2021, the Philippine Index
broke through its high, but the Nasdaq struggled in December,
failing to break through its November high, and the Dow
also
hit an intraday high in January 2022.
Since the end of this trend, including the Dow, also applies to the S&P 500, the
S&P 500 likely
reached its peak in January of that year.
yes.
At that time, it seemed like only the Nasdaq couldn't
go up
.
So, this month
, the Nasdaq needs to strongly break through its previous high
.
But the positive thing is that,
like Microsoft
, the so-called Big Tech companies are starting to stir
a bit
.
Yes, if we see signs of the
big tech companies lifting their heads and turning around,
then the
Nasdaq might break through its previous high this month. I am
looking forward to that, but for now
, I think we need to keep a close eye on how the market reacts
.
Now, what do you think the Philban Index will be tonight
?   It
is rising.  yes.
Uh, first of all, the significant rise in Samsung Electronics and
SK Hynix on Friday was due to the
U.S. market being closed,
so they couldn't react. Therefore
, that will definitely be reflected now.
Also, since we can proceed with some expectation regarding Samsung Electronics' earnings
in the U.S. market index,
yes.   I will make it
rise tonight.
Yes, because it wasn't open on Friday,
right?
yes.
Rather, the US market reflects our market,
So, it seems like today is the point where a
rebound needs to occur
.
Yes, in my opinion, I think it will
go up by about 5%
.
yes.
Philban index as well.
Exactly.  It has to go up that much,
yes.   It
seems like I can match the key now.
Yes, that is correct.
That Philban index is also very important this month
.
yes.
As mentioned earlier,
if the Nasdaq breaks through its previous high this month and starts to plummet, it needs to
rise strongly again because volatility is high, and we should see that happen
this week
.   I
think we need to see a long bullish candle to see a slight change in the atmosphere.
So, regarding the Pyeongtaek and the
US market, it is expected to rise tonight.
Also, as Manager Lee Yeo-gu mentioned last time, there has never been a case
since 1950 where the US market hit a peak in June
.
Yes, regarding the afternoon theory.   It
is quite helpful.
That is correct.   uh
.  Come to think of it, that's true.
And the reason the market was a bit weak in September was that the
July market is always strong, so the momentum shifted
from July to early August, which
also contributed to the weakness in September
.
That part is also included, and
was it just Director Lee Se-cheol?
yes.  you're right.
Director Lee Se-cheol
appeared on Environment WowNet again last Friday, I think, and spoke
very sincerely again
.
Hmm, I did an interview.
I watched the video, and
Director Lee Se-cheol mentioned that as well
.
Ah, traditionally, this semiconductor market has tended to be
a bit weak in July and August, so
hmm.
yes.  There might be some signs of adjustment, but even so, if you
compare it to baseball, it is still the second inning, the second.
yes.
You said things like that, and
seeing that was really, really helpful. The
next
7 years?
yes.  That's what he said.   That's right
.   There are still about
7 more years left.
yes.
Uh, you mentioned that.
So, uh, I've got a bit of the big picture
.
Now, so actually, if we look
into those remarks [clears throat],
uh, originally, Pilban should be
taking the lead the most this month,
yes.
Oh, so the
director of this channel is
watching all of my discussions, even down to the seasonality.
So, if the semiconductor sector shows
signs of a short-term pause in July and August,
then regarding the
other sectors that are currently showing signs of recovery...
yes.
Hey, let me go take a break while you semiconductor brother gets some rest
.  Well, kind of this kind of vibe.
yes.   It might be
directed this month.
Uh, that thought crossed my mind.
Now, how did the domestic market turn out?
Yes, I started.  Uh
, it started up by 1.22%
.  It is currently falling slightly to plus 0.61%
.
yes.
Starting at 8,186, I am
currently recording 8,100 30.
How is the KOSDAQ doing?
Yes, the KOSDAQ started down 0.23%
.  Uh, currently it is
widening the decline to -1.39%
.
If this happens, will our Dr. Wang have another KOSDAQ bearish
candle?
Yes, a bearish candle appeared.   uh
.
The KOSDAQ is showing a bearish candle today.
What do you think will happen to the KOSPI?   Since it
rose a lot on Friday, I expect
a lot of profit-taking to come out as soon as it opens.
Yes.
Anyway, Nasdaq futures are currently
rising by about 1.5% to 4%.  I suppose so.
I think the chances of beekeeping are a bit higher today.   It
started rising by over 1% but is only going up by 0.2%
.   The
possibility of beekeeping is a bit higher.
all.   That's right
.  The thought that it could absorb the selling pressure in the morning session and
go up again.
Manager Oh is definitely better than me at only giving daily pay
.
Uh,
actually, I used to be an expert on that daily chart,
because I did so much futures trading.
Yes, it's been a while since I've traded
futures.   Has
the market's color changed a bit?
I have that thought, too.
So, today is
beekeeping.
The bottom was bullish last Friday, even
though it was Friday. It's bullish, right?
I think I've hit rock bottom.  friday.
Friday floor.
Yes, on Friday,
uh, it slightly broke through the lower Bollinger band and went
down, but then buying pressure immediately came in and it just went back
up.
Last time, during the March war, the
decline stopped right at the lower Bollinger band as well.   It
is a similar pattern.
Someone said that in that comment
.  If the expert in fascinating chart analysis happens to be
unable to do it, please ask Manager Oh to
upload his Bollinger Bands.  So
hey, that's a really good comment.  Well, that’s just how
I am
.
Ah, I really want to hear that too.
therefore.
No, as for mine, I do
n't even want to do the monthly forecast anymore
.  So, Director Wang handles the monthly outlook
, and
Manager Oh takes care of the intriguing chart analysis and stuff like that. It seemed like I should
retire.
ah.
So, if
I really go on a business trip or attend an external briefing in the afternoon,
yes, Manager Oh's fascinating chart analysis,
come on over.   Oh
Shin-na.  Oh,
right.   Oh
Shin-na.
Uh, come on over, let's do it.
Ah, I have a
slightly
ominous feeling that Oshina is going to become even more popular.  [Laughs]
Uh.   I
hope you will show your support through those comments.
Oh, so you're already here? It
looks like this Dream-nim likes it, and all the die-hard fans like it too.
Oh, right.
I haven't really studied technical analysis, so I tend to just rely on my intuition
.
no.
[Clears throat] I mean, I
thought you were just doing it by feel, but you're
talking about Bollinger Bands and getting everything right, like
market conditions on Friday.
This is a daily chart. You have no idea how hard it is to get this one-day chart right
.
Uh, if the
probability stays above 57% like it is now.   yes
.
Then, actually, you can just do futures trading with this
You know.
No, the probability is well over 50%
.
Then, if you keep repeating it infinitely, the money
increases exponentially.
[Laughs]
Uh, I'm going to do that.  After I retire, I just listen to what
Manager Oh says in the morning—whether he says it's a
bullish candle or a bearish one
. If he says it's a bullish candle, I buy futures at the opening price, and, uh, sell at the closing price.
[Laughs]
I'm going to live doing that.
Ah, right, this explosive reaction.  Oh, I'm excited
.   I
look forward to it.
Oh Do-ryeong didn't just become Oh Do-ryeong for no reason
.   I
matched it so well that I became Oh Do-ryeong.
Oh, right now,
almost
everyone is saying, "Yes, please do it for Mr. Oh."
Uh, it's already beekeeping.
Ah, already switched to beekeeping again.
Wow, that's amazing.   That
is great sense.
[Laughs]
That's amazing.
Then, the way this can be applied is that
, let's say the Ogajang started
beekeeping.  But right now,
I entered a buy order for half at the opening price of 1.2, and it
dropped further to 0.8 earlier.
So now I'm going to go for an additional buy
[clears throat], and if it
ends with a bullish candle today like this,
yeah.
I think I could make more money than Warren Buffett.
How much is the contract you gifted?   It’s
ridiculously expensive these days.   I have
n't tried it lately either.   A
gift contract is
incredibly expensive these days.
So, back in the day, well, ah, well, it was
300, 200, well, 100, and so on
.
How much is the gift?
recently.
Exactly.
That's right, Mr. Oh, looking at the fascinating chart.  Because you do it
.  He sometimes
does an impression of the expert.
[Laughs]
Over there on the rooftop.
Ah, on the rooftop, what,
when we were doing push-ups.
Yes, that iscorrect.
[Laughs] I
think it's going to be funny.   uh
.   uh
.   Just how far does Mr.
Oh's talent go?   I
heard that he can even do voice impersonations.
Ah, yes.   I
do everything.  Well, Director Wang.
Uh, Mr. Oh, right now.
[Clears throat]
That's what Sagye always says at the beginning of the video
.   This
is my Cheru.
Ah, you're imitating [laughs] like that.   uh
.   Do you do that
when doing things like company analysis
?   You
don't do it in times like that?
But when the camera actually shines on me, I try to act a bit
chic and put on my mask.
Yes, that is correct.   Is
that Kin?
Yes, ah, that
gift contract over there is
about 329 million won.
300 million?
yes.
ah.
250,000 won based on 1,316 points.   that's
right.
Would that be about right?
So, when I was analyzing the new car, it came out in terms of the
number of foreign futures contracts,
yes.
These days, they just multiply the number of contracts by three
.
Yes, yes.
ah.
How were there so many?   If
you watch Choi Seul-gi TV, hit shows keep popping up like "Morning
Briefing," "Wome Shinbak," and "Byeoljubujeon," and
now "Osina" is
finally out
again.   I'm looking forward to the
colorful Oh Do-ryeong
, Manager.
Ah, I'm really looking forward to it.  I honestly
think this is the first time I've seen Chief Choi show this much anticipation for technical analysis.
Ah, why? Because it inspires trust.
Yes, that's right.   It seems like they
have a sense of style, and
oh, it seems like they have their own unique tools,
so I get
the feeling that they might be somewhat different from conventional wisdom.
Mine doesn't fit these days.
[Laughs]
Ah.
Thank you, Section Chief Oh.
Then.  I will
set aside Wednesday out of Tuesday, Wednesday, and Thursday to
visit you again with some fascinating chart analysis.  I'm going to upload that
video as a weekend video so others
can watch it again, and things like that
.
[Clears throat]